We must all turn our backs
upon the horrors of the past.
We must look to the future.
We must build a kind
of United States of Europe.
The European Community means
peace between France and Germany,
and reduction of  national egoisms.
Being awarded the Nobel Peace Prize
is actually being given a mission,
one to promote peace, the notion
of peace, wherever possible.
Europe was not created.
That is why we had the war.
Europe won't be created in one go.
It will be created by means of
concrete achievements.
Personally, I would be very upset
if Europe were damaged
during these critical times.
We have problems but we nevertheless
stick together as it has a great value.
That's what this prize means to me.
Why did we really want
to create Europe
right after
the Second World War?
Countries fought each other
during WWI and WWII,
there were brutal military conflicts,
but that is impossible today.
I couldn't pick a gun up now and fight
a friend from Germany or France.
It's not possible.
This first common market,
these first supranational institutions
mean Europe is starting to unite.
This Nobel Peace Prize
acts as a uniting factor
at a time when the economy
could actually mean "economic war".
Come on, look back for a moment!
Ask yourselves how Europe looked like
fifty years ago.
Solidarity is being rather
sorely tested at the moment
but it's true that it may be
a good idea to remember that,
unlike our parents and grandparents,
we haven't experienced war.
Only with a strong, united Europe
can the Europeans, and the world,
really prosper.
Since the Wall came down I've felt
I'm finally living at the right time,
because the building of the Wall was
a negative turning point in my life.
Warmly welcome to our family.
Our new Europe is born.
Europe hasn't been created just for us
but for all European countries.
Opening our arms to these countries is
wonderful, it's letting our heart speak.
We can live normally,
we don't have to be afraid of anything.
We may get to know
the rest of the world.
1st May 2004,
I was among all those
who were moved to tears
because it was such a symbolic moment.
Our return to the community of nations,
where Poland had to find its place.
I am very proud of this and
I would like all young people,
in fact not only the young
but everyone in Poland,
to feel as proud as I am.
I am thirty years old and,
as a child, I survived this war.
I have never visited Europe
and I would like to visit Europe
and be a European citizen.
I would like to see
how people live there.
That would be a great feeling.
We have today been able to
give a very clear message
to the Western Balkans:
they will become part of our family.
I was very small
when I lost my mother during the war.
Some things you can never forget
but we have to look ahead,
because of our children,
because of Bosnia and Herzegovina,
because of the future
of Bosnia and Herzegovina.
We will never be reminded enough
of how much this peace,
now so deeply rooted,
is a revolution
compared to a history of never-ending,
dramatic and bloody conflicts.
All I can say is...
carry on fighting with peaceful means
so that Europe remains united.
I love Europe.